hey guys and welcome back to the channel
uh today has been a good day for some of
my viewers at least two of them have
reached out to me saying they got meta
offers and one of them even called me
handsome which is how you know he was a
dude so let's go ahead and get into it
we've got another video for you all it
is a Friday I'm going to go out after
this so I'm excited today we're going to
be talking about Google Docs okay so
like I mentioned today we are going to
be talking about Google Docs now I
assume this is a product that most of
you are familiar with but in the event
that you are not let me show off an
example use case so we've got some sort
of text document you know we've got one
line over here that's already been
written Jordan is dot dot dot and then
you've got three people over here all
actively editing it at the same time and
you know if you're editing this document
or you have it open you can actually see
other people making changes as they make
them so as you can see we've got Kate
Upton writing that Jordan is handsome
Megan Fox writing that he's sexy Tech
lead writing that he's dumb perhaps
because Jordan called him out in one of
his previous videos over all his crypto
scamming uh but that is another topic
for another time so let's talk about
some problem requirements uh I kind of
made three of these even though this
could probably be summarized in like
three words just to fill up a slide's
worth of data but the point is that more
or less if I write you should be able to
see it in real time if you write I
should be able to see it in real time
and basically if the document has a ton
of users on it at once all of those
rights should be propagated to all of
the other readers in real time hopefully
that makes sense cool and of course
another important thing is that you know
we don't want people to have documents
that are out of sync if I make a right I
don't want to be able to see my right
and someone else can see my right but
then a third user cannot it's important
that they all eventually converge to the
same state even if it's not entirely
instant okay so let's go through some
capacity estimates because these are
going to be pretty important for what we
ultimately end up discussing so the
first thing is that uh I'm going to keep
this one abstract um you know I don't
need to go into any specific numbers
because the whole point of this problem
in particular or the reason I want to
talk about it is because I want to
basically be able to design it for
arbitrary scale so with that being said
let's imagine we have like billions of
users billions of different documents
you can have you know thousands of users
editing a document at once and
attempting to read it which of course is
going to be a lot of load each document
can have hundreds of pages and uh the
sizes can be in the kilobytes but
frankly if you have hundreds of pages
you could even be looking at documents
in the sizes of megabytes which would be
pretty bad so of course if we want to be
able to be processing these rights as
fast as possible possible both the
number of writers right I said you know
literally thousands so that's going to
be really tough to actually transmit
those changes from writer to writer or
the writer to reader and also the
document sizes if there are lots of
kilobytes can both be
problematic okay so I'm basically going
to go over this problem by starting out
with a really terrible solution and then
we'll gradually make them better and
better as we break down what is wrong
with each solution so the first one is
going to be very naive where basically
we've got client one over here and
client 2 over here they're both
connected to some server via
websockets uh the reason we want
websockets is so that you know if I make
a change in real time the server can
actually push it to the other client and
the general idea is you know I make a
change right so I send my version of the
document over to the server I grab a
lock in order to do so so that this guy
can't send his document over at the same
time because otherwise you know who wins
we have no clue so I send over my
document uh it goes over to S3 or
wherever the server sends it to some
sort of persistent data store and then
basically it says okay let me look at
all the websockets that I have for this
document send the document back to them
so it's now in step two going to send my
document over to the other client and
the reason it needs to send it first
before this client can actually go ahead
and grab the lock again is so that this
client can incorporate my edits into
their document so you know they're going
to do some sort of
merging and then in step three they're
going to grab that server lock and then
they're going to in turn make the update
and then that is going to be sent to S3
so as a as a result of this lock and as
a result of sending out my edits to
everyone else uh and as a result of the
websockets we are actually able to
achieve real-time editing here however
the issue is it's just going to be
really freaking slow why is that well
like I mentioned the document is large
and so you don't really want to be
sending it over the network every single
time you make a write when all you did
was type let's say one or two
characters additionally we are using a
lock and when there are locks you can
have contention especially when multiple
different people are attempting to grab
that lock at the same time and so
ideally we would like to be able to
avoid both of these things it's not so
easy but we'll talk about that later so
let's make this thing a little bit
better this is what I'd like to call a
bad solution so in our bad solution we
still have a lock but now instead of
doing anything like that what we can do
is basically say Hey you know in order
to make a right grab the lock first and
then insert you know let's say character
a at position three so what's going to
happen is that the server is going to
lock no one else can write it's going to
send that character to our database you
know maybe it's more practical to use a
database here instead of S3 because
we're doing one character at a time and
S3 stores the whole document but uh the
point is we send that character there we
then go ahead and say okay we now have
to send that right to all of our clients
so again we're doing this all over
websocket and then now finally this guy
incorporates this right and then they
can send a new right which is going to
be valid over to the server and grab the
lock once again the process repeats so
this is going to be a lot better because
now we don't have to send full documents
however in order to avoid some sort of
right conflict or merge conflict or
whatever you really want to call it uh
we need to again use a lock right so
that my changes in Step One are
integrated into this guy's document
before he makes his right in step three
and so again there's going to be lots of
contention on the lock because in
reality there's not just going to be two
users or well most of the time there
will just be two users or even one user
but in the really bad Edge case which is
what we want mostly want to focus on
here because it it makes it an
interesting problem uh you can have
thousands of users writing at the same
time and you don't want their rights to
take you know 5 10 seconds due to trying
to grab a lock over and over again so
basically the idea again is that uh the
issue with the lock is we have to
process all of the previous rights in
order to make our own and to process all
of those previous rights we need to make
sure that there's basically some
concurrency control via the lock so what
would be a better solution so this one
is going to be pretty interesting
because it allows us to actually avoid
using the lock so the question is you
know if I write and you write at the
same time right we're both doing
something like hey insert character o at
position one that's what client one's
doing and then client two is going to do
insert character G at position five now
if you think about it right if I insert
character o at position one I go from
coding and now all of a sudden I have
cing
kudin I don't know why I made up this
example it's bad but uh yeah and so so
if this guy originally wanted to insert
character G at position five right
because we had 0 1 2 3 4 5 it would have
been coding now after he does that
what's going to happen is 0 1 2 3 4 5
now all of a sudden if this guy's right
gets processed second we have
cigan whatever that is and so as you can
see uh the order in which we process the
rights actually affects where we want to
insert those character characters and
this is kind of the premise behind
something known as operational transform
right so operational transform is saying
hey if I see this right and then I see
this other right I have to actually
transform this guy so that now we're no
longer inserting that character G at
position five but we're going to do it
at position six now you might say to
yourself wow there must be a ton of edge
cases here and to be honest there
probably are uh but fortunately there
are Engineers with no Lives who have
actually managed to tackle those for us
so operational transform is something
that has actually been utilized by
something like Google docs for many many
years in real life so for example you
know let's uh let's try and demonstrate
it via a diagram we have some sort of
centralized server right and the idea
here is that if I'm sending over right
number one and this guy is sending over
right number two but on his client it's
saying hey I've I've not seen right
number one yet you know I've only I've
only seen up to write zero so then uh
the server is able to say oh you know
what if this guy hasn't seen right one
he needs to incorporate right one and
that means we need to transform right
number two you know as if right number
one had come first and that is going to
give us two Prime and so what's now
going to happen is that we'll say you
know we're going to send one back to
this guy and two prime back to this guy
and one back to this guy and two prime
back to this guy and then you know we
can have some sort of client side
optimization such that this guy sees his
right until he receives the actual one
from the server and you know we don't
need to talk about that too much but the
point is we do have to transform rights
depending on the order that they come in
and each client is going to have to keep
state of how many rights it's actually
seen so that we know whether or not to
transform that right on the server right
so hopefully that makes sense however
even this while it is a completely
feasible solution that has worked for
many years on the Google Docs team uh it
does have some issues so for starters we
basically need a server that has to see
all of the rights so what does that mean
this is kind of the same concept as
something like single leader replication
right where as long as all of the rights
go to that same single leader everything
is in good shape however as a result of
that this single server can become a
bottleneck and so you know if we now
have this guy over here and this guy
over here and this guy over here and
they're all submitting rights over to
our server our server has to order them
all which means it's going to have to
perform some amount of locking right
it's uh it's not going to have to force
everyone to wait for an incoming right
to come in but you know it is going to
be bounded by both uh its its like
literal networking capacity and also
just using something like a blocking que
and so as a result uh This Server might
not be able to hold up properly if we
genuinely have thousands of people
writing to it at the same time so now
this is where we're going to start
getting real complicated right because I
made this video once already it was
complicated enough and then I decided to
make it even more complicated so let's
try and walk through it and we'll do the
best that we can
so if you recall I love talking about
crdts on this channel the reason for
that is because Martin kman loves
talking about crdts and I love Martin
kman uh that's the guy who wrote ddia
for uh for reference but generally the
idea is that um as opposed to having to
send every single right through a server
it would be great if we could send data
from place to place in a manner such
that you know not every single server
needs to actually see every single right
obviously every client has to see every
single right but if we can you know have
three servers instead and you randomly
send a right to one of those three
servers and then one of those three
sends them to all the clients uh that
would mean that we could then support a
lot more rights at the same time so that
is the idea behind using a crdt here so
we want to use something called a text
editing crdt but before I go into that
let me remind everyone what a crdt is so
a crdt is basically saying hey I've got
some data living on all these different
servers and even though right now all of
those servers may seem uh different
states when they eventually communicate
with one another they'll all converge to
the same state right so I've got a node
one node 2 node 3 I've got state state
Prime State double Prime and when these
guys all eventually end up you know
sending their data to one another
they'll all converge to State triple
prime or something like
that so hopefully that makes sense from
a very abstract point of view but we'll
start talking about that a lot more
concretely in the coming
slides cool so a high level overview of
what we want to be doing with crdts is
like I mentioned it is going to allow us
to have more right servers so you know
imagine we've got these two guys writing
at the same time they don't actually
both have to go to this server a over
here in fact one of them can go to
server B one of them can go to server a
we can then basically just multicast or
you know use websockets or anything like
that the point is we can send the right
out to every other one of our clients
and as long as they both get as long as
all of those clients get the right it
doesn't actually matter what order they
come in we can just merge them together
using our crdt merge function and then
we'll all eventually converge to the
same state now again I've said there's
some sort of merge function obviously
I'm going to have to Define what that
merge function is for a text document
but the idea is you know if this guy is
saying O at position 2 and this guy is
saying a at position one there is some
sort of merge function that it actually
won't matter what order these rights
come to you in and you can all basically
end up seeing the same document
regardless of their order
cool so now in order to start defining
what our crdt is going to look like for
these text documents I'm going to cover
the concept of a state-based crdt versus
an operational crdt so a state crdt
means we're actually sending the entire
state of what it is that we're trying to
maintain and in the case of Google docs
we're trying to maintain a text document
so what that would mean was you know if
I'm a client and I make a write I take
my updated text document and I send it
you know to either the server or to
every other client it doesn't really
matter it just has to eventually get to
every single other client so I would
send that full text document and then we
would have a merge function that takes
the two versions of text documents right
so if I have my own local version and I
get an incoming version I have to have
some sort of merge function you can
almost think of this like uh the git
algorithm to literally merge two files
in code and the idea there
is that that merge function has to be
commutative associative and item potent
so what that means is you know if I
receive your file or you receive my file
we have the same result and if I receive
your file and then I receive your file
again I get the same exact result as if
I had just received it once that means
it's item potent so the one issue here
is uh again like we can do this right if
we use something like a git merge
function with our text documents we
would be able to resolve those changes
and I could just send my file to you and
then you would merge it in and I could
send my file to you again and you would
merge it in and it would be the same
however this is going to be tough
because the document is big if we have
an 100 page document I don't want to
have to send that to every single other
reader of the document that's going to
be really rough uh and it's going to
make for a bad day so what could we
actually do instead well we've already
talked about this quite a bit this video
we're better off just sending the
operations that we do on the state so in
this case the operation is going to be
insert X at position y now again we
still need to Define ourselves a merge
function that is going to be commutative
right so it doesn't matter the order
that you receive these operations in and
also associative which is similar uh you
can go look up the math function because
I'm blanking on it at the moment anyways
the point is with these operational
crdts one problem with them is that they
aren't item potent right if I receive
the operation insert X at position Y and
then I receive that operation again how
do I know if it was the same operation
as before or someone's actually just
inserting the same character at the same
position again it's not exactly easy to
tell so we have to do a little bit of
extra work to actually make this thing
item potent so if that I'm a client and
I receive this insert xit position y I
don't apply it for a second time so
we're going to need some additional
metadata with each one of these
operations and then additionally the
question is how can we actually make
these character insertions commutative
so the problem with that is if you call
all the way back to our operational
transform thing you know it actually
depends what order these guys are
processed in so if I said insert G at
position 5 and then I said insert uh o
at position one then what would actually
happen is I would go from
codin to
coding to cing and that's actually what
we want so that's a different result
than if I process them in a different
order so keep in mind that order does
actually matter for these insertions how
can we make it so that order doesn't
matter and that is where our merge
function is going to come in so actually
we're going to change the way that we
Define our document a little bit so the
first thing is that rather than uh
giving every single character in our
document an index from you know like an
integer index so 0 1 2 3 4 5 actually
what we'll do instead is we'll take the
first character in our document assign
it to position zero the last character
in our document assign it to position
one and then from there we take every
single other character and basically
evenly distribute them out along that
zero to one timeline so you know for
example if we have four characters we
would have c d n g d is going to be at
33 n is going to be at 66 so now what's
going to happen is now someone else
comes along they want to insert a
character so if I want to insert o
between character C and between
character D I actually take these two
numbers and then I just divide them by
two right so that's actually going to
put me at let's
see1
165 and so this is where I'm going to be
inserting position o so I would say o
at65 and that's what I'm going to write
over the network insert o
at165 cool and then the same thing over
here if I wanted to insert I between d
and n I would take 33. 66 split them in
two and that's that's going to obviously
be 0.5 so now all of a sudden I have i
at position
.5 now uh one thing to note is that you
can actually add a small random Jitter
so maybe instead of doing 0.5 I do
05012 or something like that because
that way if someone else wants to write
a character you know
coding like that their random Jitter
puts them at
0524 and that way it's actually
deterministic whether e is going to be
in front of I or not right so if I say
write at 0 5024 now I know that every
single client is going to
deterministically know that e is in
front of I if I had them both at 0. five
then it's possible that some clients
would have e after I it's possible that
some clients would have E before I but
if you think about this what's actually
happening here is when we do this
bsection if you think about it it
doesn't actually matter the order in
which the characters are inserted right
because regardless of whether this guy
goes first or this guy goes first o is
still going to be at uh position 16 and
I is still going to be at position .5
and so this is the basis behind how we
would Model A text document in order to
make a crdt of it however this is not
entirely easy right there's still going
to be some edge cases here so let's
imagine one that's called interleaving
so this is one that Martin kman talks a
little bit about on YouTube but the idea
is let's imagine I want to write the
word cat right so assuming there's
nothing in the text field so far we just
have some start and end character at
zero and one the characters for cat
would be at 0.25 50 and .75 because
we're Distributing them evenly and if
someone else is writing bird we would
have the characters .20 4060 and 80 and
keep in mind that basically the idea is
we want to organize these characters
over the number line so that would mean
you know we've got B at0 20 c at0 25 I
at 0 4 and on and on and on missing this
pattern and so what's basically happened
is because we've tried to insert two
words that are slightly different
lengths at the same place in our
document the characters actually get
interleafed what we would want is to
just have you know cat bird or something
like that or bird
cat now fortunately uh there are a lot
of researchers who have devoted a good
amount of time to working through all of
these edge cases and ultimately Tech
crdts have now gotten in a pretty good
spot such that you can effectively you
know follow some sort of function that
when you type of character uh there's
some client library on your machine that
converts it to the appropriate operation
for the text crdt and then as soon as
they've converted that to the
appropriate operation you can send that
in any indiscriminate order to all other
clients and they will be able to
reconstruct the state of the document
that looks exactly the same as yours
which is really really
cool now the last thing that I wanted to
talk about is going to be item potent
because I mentioned that uh you know
assuming that I send you an operation
insert X at position y if you receive it
multiple times are they unique rights or
are they the same rights so how can we
actually ensure that they are different
and this is going to spiral into a whole
deep discussion uh so let's see if we
can go ahead and follow it okay so again
I receive a right as a client have I
seen it before have I not how do I know
well for starters one approach that we
can take is that each write could have
an Associated uu ID with it and then I
locally just keep some sort of set of uu
IDs that I've seen and assuming that I
have not seen it before I apply it and
assuming that I have seen it before I
don't and that's going to work uh that's
totally fine but now for every single
character typed or every single write
done I have to store an additional uu ID
now uu IDs aren't that small you know
that could be another uh 16 characters
or possibly even more uh per right so it
could actually be significant overhead
another possibility would actually be to
use something like version vectors so
version vectors I've discussed pretty
extensiv ly on this channel more so in
the concepts videos because they aren't
too relevant for most problems but the
idea of a version Vector is that you
know if I see um a right with a smaller
version Vector than uh the version
Vector that I'm currently holding on my
client I know that I've already
processed that right if the right has a
bigger version Vector than the one that
I have stored uh for my local document
then I have not processed it so we can
talk about this in a second how does it
actually look in practice let's go ahead
and make things concrete
okay so I am going to now Define some
weird slight sort of kind of version
Vector uh just to reduce a little bit of
the space overhead when sending these
rights over the network but uh I think
it does still work so let's imagine
we've got two clients number one number
two and two servers A and B and actually
we've got a third client over here so
let's imagine that this guy is going to
make a right to server a the right is
going to be basically given uh the
sequence number A1 because it's the
first write that's been processed by
server a we also have this guy writing
to server a and since it gets there
after A1 it is going to be labeled A2
now keep in mind that uh in our crdt
system we can have rights being
processed by multiple different servers
that's the whole appeal it's going to
allow us to ensure that we don't have
any bottlenecks when making rights so
that means this guy over here can now
make a right to server B and because
it's the first one processed on server B
that is going to have the index B1 or
the sequence number
B1 okay so like I mentioned we're just
going to assign every single write an ID
based on the server that processed it
and how many rights that server has
processed so A1 A6 A10 B1 B20 doesn't
matter and the reason we're doing this
is because for example a typical version
Vector would look something like this so
A1 would look like 1 comma 0 because
there's one right to the first server
zero rights to B uh A2 would look like
you know 2 comma 0 but we don't really
need all the information of other
servers right because the point is this
version Vector actually gets bigger as
there are more number of servers that
can process our rights and we really
only care about actually what number
right this is on one particular server
so it's going to save us a little bit of
space to represent rights using this
kind of um server sequence number it's
almost like a Lamport clock really so
the idea is we're going to save space
compared to the typical version Vector
which is a vector whereas this is more
of a Lamport clock but uh eventually we
are still going to have to use actual
version vectors so I'll talk about that
in a second but the problem with version
vectors is they have a length equal to
the number of servers so if we had to
actually send that over the network with
every single right you know let's say we
had 20 different servers processing
rights for this given document that
could get pretty hefty cool so now how
are we actually going to use this on a
client in order to make sure that we
haven't process to given right before so
let's say this client is me and the
first thing that's going to happen is I
see WR A1 I process it I haven't seen
any rights from server a before so I'm
good to go then I see WR A2 now all of a
sudden I know that um you know I've seen
two wres from server a and then finally
if I see A1 again I will know that
that's a duplicate because right now I'm
actually going to keep a local version
Vector which looks something like this 2
comma 0 meaning I've seen two rights
from server a I've seen zero rights from
server B so if something comes in like
A1 I can look at the A and X over here
say you know what I must have already
seen this already and now I'm good to go
cool however we are going to have to
continue this a little bit so the issue
is that we're not actually guaranteeing
the order in which rights are getting to
the client so even though they're all
being processed by a uh you know the
first time around I'm not actually
saying how this right is going from a to
say this guy over here it could go
through b it could go over here it could
go go over multicast it could go over
UDP it doesn't really matter the point
is I'm trying to make a system that is
completely arbitrary in terms of the
number of servers that accept document
rights and also how those servers
communicate with one another now if I
made some sort of guarantee where every
single time a server received a right it
would just synchronously go and transmit
that right to every other client over
TCP this type of thing couldn't happen
but if I don't what could happen is that
you know I could write A2 over here
and then what could actually happen now
is this guy sees A2 before it sees A1
and that would be a problem because you
know now I would increment my version
Vector to 2 comma 0 and if I were to see
A1 I would think it was a duplicate even
though it isn't so how can we avoid
actually receiving and processing those
rights out of order
right so this is what we're going to be
talking about over here so let's imagine
I am over here this is me I'm
maintaining some sort of
document and in order to get the state
of this document I've seen six rights
that originated from server a I've seen
nine rights that have originated from
server B and I've seen four rights that
have originated from server C now let's
imagine just randomly I happen to get a
notification that hey right C6 has just
come in well the issue now is wait a
second I can't process C6 I haven't seen
C5 and I need it so what can we actually
do in order to get it well that's the
question but again the idea is um you
know it is possible depending on my
network topology of document writing
servers that I could receive a right
like C6 before I receive a right like C5
there are ways to avoid this happening
by actually just using guaranteed
ordered messaging through TCP and having
every single right server instantly send
that message out to every single client
uh but again I want to make this as
flexible as possible because I don't
want these right servers to become a
bottle NE I want to make rights as
quickly and seamlessly as possible so
again you know we have choices to do TCP
versus UDP uh we have choices on you
know which right server is going to you
know write to another right server which
is then going to forward those messages
out to clients these are all things that
have trade-offs and uh honestly we could
probably discuss them for an hour you
know you could do like a a round
topology where you pass the messages
from one server to the next to the next
to the next and then to clients there
are many different things that we can do
here and the point is I want to come up
with a solution that is robust
regardless of what order the messages
are delivered to the client in cool so
let's actually go ahead and keep talking
about that so like I mentioned you can
receive messages out of order and when
we do what we can do is actually go
ahead and when we first make a right we
can persist it to a database right so we
want to be sure that uh none of our
rights are actually getting lost the
reason being that that ultimately if I
need to uh get a right because I haven't
seen C5 over here then I want to be able
to actually just request it from some
server so we'll talk about that in a
second but the idea is you know here's
me I'm
writing I write to server C apologies
for the ambulance I write to server C
and right before server C actually sends
this right out to the clients it is
going to put this right C5 over in a
database which I'll just call the rights
database and then after that it can
actually send to everyone else as
necessary so we now know that C5 is
guaranteed to be in a database before a
single client even sees it and so now
what's going to happen is let's say I'm
this guy over here and I've seen C4 and
all of a sudden for whatever reason I
see message C8 I can't process this
thing yet because I'm missing C5 C6 and
C7 and I know that if I'm seeing C8 it
means that this server over here has
already put it in a database and gotten
an acknowledgement back because of the
fact that I'm waiting on that
acknowledgement to send this right to
everyone else so if I see a right I know
it's already in the database and now if
I really need to because C5 C6 and C7
haven't come in yet I can just request
them from the database so hopefully that
makes sense ideally you should just be
receiving most of these rights from the
server but occasionally one might get
dropped and you might not receive it and
then you can just pull it from the
database cool so another small thing to
note is uh you know if this database is
actually indexed by both the server and
the number of the right it could make
your reads a little bit faster so if I
have C1 C2 C3 and they're all ordered
and sorted that is going to make
fetching C5 C6 and C7 a lot faster than
having to do a linear scan through that
table and just looking for all of them
individually cool so the reason I also
wanted to talk about that was because it
is relevant for new clients right so
it's great when you're connected to all
of the right servers the whole time and
you can just hear wrs as they come in
however if I'm a new person and I
haven't been writing to the document and
now I need to load a snapshot of the
document so that I can start getting the
active changes to it I have to be able
to fetch it from somewhere cool so how
is this actually going to work well the
first question is can we read it from
our rights database right can I from
that rights database that we discussed
in the last slide recreate our document
and the answer is yes right because I
know that all of the rights from server
C are going to be in here there might be
a server a
database just like that and I can read
those there might be a server B
database and so what would have to
happen is my client would have to read
from here here and here in order to get
all of those rights assuming there are
three different right servers and the
problem with that is that even though it
works it is going to be slow because as
We Know when we're trying to make a
quick write having to do some sort of
aggregation over multiple different uh
distributed nodes is always going to be
pretty tough so the idea is uh that in
addition to that uh you know besides
having to do like an aggregation we
would also have to actually sort these
rights by character because right now
they're sorted by the order that they
came in but you know this could have
like character .56 this could have
character. 21 this could
be99 and I'll make that more Concrete in
a second
but ideally instead what we want to do
in order to simplify this problem a
little bit is use derived data because
reading from those writs tables is
probably just going to be too slow when
we're first starting up so what would be
a little bit better well let's say I'm a
writer I want to write to the server so
I make a write saying
insert X at y okay the rights table is
now going to say hey this was right C5
insert ERT X at Y and then from there
what we can use is change data capture
to take this right and actually
transform it into a better format for us
to then read it down the line so now
rather than saying hey C5 insert X at Y
what we can do is put it into this
document snapshots table right which
we're going to be deriving via change
data capture so it stays
consistent and then from there once we
actually do that now as opposed to
having C1 C2 C3 like that order we would
actually have you know character Zero
character1 character Point 2 and so it's
going to be a lot faster to read that
database we don't have to resort the
characters now I know that's all a bit
abstract which is why I decided to write
it out in the next uh slide over here so
now we're going to actually visualize
those two database schemas so we have
the wrs table which is what we
synchronously write to every single time
that we want to make a new right to our
document and then we have the document
snapshot table which is is going to be
derived from the rights table via change
data capture CDC so let's imagine that
we've written the word Jordan right so
let's say R is the first character
that's getting getting written that gets
put at 0. five then you know we put in O
at 0.25 and at 75 oh you know J gets put
between uh the starting character and O
so it's at 0.125 then we've got a at 625
and D at 56125 now again if I wanted to
create the whole document I would have
to take all of this and I would have to
sort it by this column right here which
is again going to be o of n log n to the
number of characters in our document and
if you have a 100 page document that is
not trivial additionally if our document
is partitioned then it's really not
trivial because now we have to go to a
bunch of different partitions and it's
probably partitioned like this right
where each server is writing to the same
database and so now we have to fetch
these guys then we have to fetch these
guys and then we have to actually sort
them and let's say we only wanted to
fetch you know out of an 100 page
document we wanted to fetch the first
page of our document now I have to
actually fetch all of these guys do a
full sort on this column and then only
take the first page of it which is maybe
these two values right or not even those
two values it would be uh the J and the
O so I'd have to do all this sorting uh
of a huge document only to then uh you
know have to only take a small chunk of
it and do that over multiple different
noes on the other hand if I wanted to do
this in our document snapshot table it's
going to be a lot easier why is that
well as you can see all of our
characters are actually ordered by their
indexs as you can see it's clearly a lot
easier to just read Jordan here as
opposed to having to have it all jumbled
up on the writer's table side and so now
let's imagine you know instead of having
just six characters here I had a th000
characters and I only wanted to load the
first third of them so I want the first
page well what I could do is partition
my document actually by the the range of
the characters right so the first third
of them are going to go on one partition
the second third are on another
partition the last third are on another
partition hey now I only want the first
third of my document I just go read this
partition and that's super easy to do as
opposed to the other solution where I
have to load everything and then sort it
so hopefully that makes a little bit of
sense for the logic behind why we want a
document snapshot
table so what does this show General
process look like for new clients that
are starting up well the first thing
that's going to happen is we're going to
subscribe to changes right because we
want to make sure that when we subscribe
uh we aren't going to be missing
anything so now what might happen is you
know we might get something like a C5
right before we've even actually fetched
the document from our document snapshot
database but because we don't have um
you know the the precursor rights you
know we aren't having C4 yet uh we have
to go fetch that so now we're fetching
that from the database and what's going
to happen is we now get a snapshot of
the
database with our version Vector
associated with that snapshot which is
hey we've seen 10 rights from uh server
a 12 rights from server B three rights
from server C and now remember I just
received C5 so I'm saying shoot I need
C4 where can I go to get it I can go to
the rights database give me C4 C4 comes
back now all of a sudden I'm completely
caught up and all subsequent mess
mesages will come from the right servers
so this is a way to guarantee that we
will never drop an individual right once
we get our actual document state there's
no race condition in which we can you
know somehow miss one of these rights
and then never get it back if we do miss
a right we'll know because we'll see a
higher one coming in and then we can
request the misr from the rights
database so think of this sort of like a
Delta protocol where this is like your
state and this is your
operation Operation poll
and this is your Operation
Push is this a bit over engineered for
Google Docs maybe so if we want to make
an arbitrary type of real-time editor
where you can have as many right servers
as you want communicating with each
other in whatever method that they want
to communicate in whether that's
multicast or you know a star method or
any sort of just around the world method
it doesn't really matter the point is
that using a solution like this will
ensure that we all are going to converge
to the same state and we're also not
going to be doubly applying certain
rights cool so the last thing I wanted
to touch upon quickly was you know
Jordan you've made this whole over
engineered solution couldn't we just do
this with just a document snapshot
database and the answer is actually yes
you could right so you know if this is
server a server B and server C and these
guys are set up so that any of our
clients can make rights to them you know
insert X at y what we could actually do
is just you know store our document
state in
here you know so again it would be like
first you write to the document database
and then second you can propagate that
right out to the world and that would
work it would work just fine however if
you think about it guess what's a
bottleneck now a database so it used to
be the case that you know just having
one server was a bottleneck now we have
many servers but just one database and
so making sure that uh we actually have
this kind of three-prong system of as
many servers as we want as many write
databases as we want and then a document
snapshot database keep in mind the
document snapshot database is updated
via change data capture which means it
can go as slowly as we need it to so
it's not going to become a bottleneck we
actually have a pretty robust system
here
cool so the last question is going to be
you know we have this document snapshot
database down here and the question now
becomes where is this version Vector
coming from right we need to actually be
able to store this with the data well
there's a couple things that we can do
for starters we can basically
reconstruct the uh version Vector from
our right IDs how would we do that well
if I go back up here to the schema I
could do a linear scan down this table
and say okay well the highest right from
B that I've seen is three the highest
right from a that I've seen is three so
our version Vector is actually going to
be 3 comma 3
now that's feasible except it's pretty
darn stupid if our data is on multiple
different partitions because then all of
a sudden we have to make some sort of uh
distributed transaction because one of
the partitions could change after we've
already queried it uh it actually gets
pretty complicated so maybe that's not
actually going to be the best thing to
do what we could do instead is actually
keep a separate version Vector table for
our document snapshots right so now
we're getting even more complicated here
instead of of just having a document
snapshot table we're also going to have
a version Vector table and so what this
is going to allow us to do is uh as long
as it stays in sync with our document
snapshot uh we are in good shape
otherwise the client gets messed up
right so if I say you know I just loaded
a document and snapshot uh with a
version Vector that's less recent than
it now all of a sudden I might end up
applying double rights because you know
my document uh I'm going to basically
see a right coming in uh I already
Incorporated that right into my document
snapshot however the version Vector is
telling me that I haven't Incorporated
that right so now I'm going to double
apply it or another bad thing would be
okay so I have a really recent version
Vector but a not recent document
snapshot now all of a sudden I'm going
to see a right that comes in it's not
reflected in my document snapshot but my
version Vector is telling me that I've
already seen it now I never apply that
right so again it's really important
that we keep these two in sync and uh
you guys aren't going to like this one
but we're actually going to use a
two-phase commit the reason being that
again like I mentioned when we have
something like derived data that is
going over change data capture I don't
really actually care about keeping this
thing that fast because it's not in the
critical path right the critical path of
me being able to submit a right as a
client is just these two guys right here
anything happening over here can be nice
and slow and that includes the two-phase
commit so what's actually going to
happen now is we've got our version
Vector store
we do some you know we have some
intermediary server that's reading these
events and then two-phase committing
over to these
two
cool so I think that covers everything
that I wanted to cover just about I've
over engineered the crap out of this
thing as I love to do and as a result
now we can just have as many right
servers as we could possibly want in our
life submit one right to literally any
of them send it around to our heart's
content uh and then everyone should be
in good shape so we've got our right
cluster servers because this guy is
going to be the
writer this guy is going to be the
reader on the
right and so we can submit a right to
any of these uh servers in a right
cluster server the first thing that it
actually has to do is go submit to our
right
databases and the idea here is uh it
doesn't really matter um you know how we
partition these things but it's going to
be super useful if uh we make sure that
basically you know if I have a all of
the rights from a should go onto the
same server because this guy at some
point might request a bunch of different
rights from server a to catch up and so
as a result it would be great if they're
on the same location uh it would also be
nice if you know these guys were writing
for the same document and were on the
same server but uh they don't have to be
again I'm typically just just going to
be requesting for one server at a time
and so as a result we can Partition by
this server ID it would also be nice if
we index on the right order because
let's say you know C8 comes in and I've
only seen C4 now I want C5 C6 and C7 it
would be a lot faster for me to know
exactly where those are if those numbers
are sorted in our database cool so the
next aspect of this is this guy can now
go sending out rights you know in step
two to their heart's content they can
send them to all the other clients as
they please and the clients can go merge
them in they're a crdt so it doesn't
really matter what the order is going to
be when they get there okay so this is
going to be our CR path right here
everything on the bottom left and now
what's going to happen is we also
perform change data capture where we
take all of the rights from our right
database and we actually are going to
convert them into document snapshots and
the document snapshot has two components
it's got the version Vector associated
with that document snapshot and is also
going to have the document snapshot
itself where a document snapshot is just
going to be all of the characters in the
document but just ordered uh in terms of
their index in that document so that way
we can actually partition them by the
range of the index of that character and
uh it's going to allow us to you know
just say load one page of the text
document at a time which is going to be
really nice cool we can also of course
get that version vector and that's going
to allow us to know the version Vector
corresponding to one particular document
over here um the one thing I should note
is that I thought it would be kind of
useful to use hbase for our document
snapshot database the reason being that
there's probably going to be a decent
amount of metadata associated with each
write and to keep reads as possible it
would be great if we could just grab the
columns that we care about which is just
going to be the character and the
position that the character is at so H
Bas I think could help a little bit in
practice who knows you'd have to run a
bunch of benchmarks cool and then
finally the last aspect of this puzzle
that I haven't really spoken about
because it's kind of given for any
problem like this is a cache if there
are certain documents that tons of
people are opening up per day uh we
probably want some sort of lru in memory
cache to actually store for all of those
characters and their positions we can
just do that in rdus uh you know you can
pull these in as we're trying to read
them and then use lru to make sure that
the unpopular ones get evicted and the
popular ones stay in there so to
actually go ahead and read a document
just to reiterate the first step is
going to be that we would get its
document snapshot so 1 a and one rather
sorry 1 a and 1B is going to be reading
from these two guys then all of a sudden
I have a snapshot in the version Vector
associated with it I can start
subscribing to these servers over here
the current right servers I'm going to
receive a right and I'm going to say
shoot you know what I might be missing a
couple of wres let me actually reach out
to one of these right databases over
here to catch up and then once you're
caught up you're good to go and you're
finished well guys that was a lot um I
didn't really focus nearly as much on
the actual right ordering inv version
Vector stuff in the last video but I
actually think it's quite important
because uh when you have a crd like this
um actually making sure that you don't
lose any of the rights and you don't
double apply any of the rights is uh is
a bit of a struggle so with that being
said I hope you enjoyed the video and I
will see you in the next one